>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Debra Band: It's an
extraordinary honor to be with you
to share my fourth illuminated book.
I'm so very grateful to Dr.
Brenner for inviting me.
Each time I come to this building,
it's like entering a temple.
But, of course, unlike a religious
temple, it belongs equally to all
of us, of all intellectual
and spiritual paths.
Now, this work is expressly
Jewish, but its core ideas
of fusing spiritual and
secular relate to all faiths.
This morning, I'm introducing
you to my vision
of how we can fully fuse our
souls and our modern minds
through this new book, which
presents the customs and liturgies
of one of the most important moments
in all Jewish tradition
that occurs every week.
On Friday evenings, the
Shechinah, in Jewish mysticism,
the most accessible emanation of
the divine spirit, enters synagogues
and homes as the sunsets
and Sabbath arrives.
As we shed our weekday schedules
and demands, she wraps us in a veil
of ecstatic, exalted imagery
that couldn't be more different
from the imagery of our daily lives.
Ideas about the beauty of creation,
of divine wisdom, and energy flowing
and sparkling through
the material world.
We express these ideas in a
sunset synagogue prayer service,
followed up around the home dining
table, in a tradition developed
by the Jewish mystics, the
Kabbalists, of 16th-century Tifat,
or Safed, in northern Israel.
The companions and followers
of the remarkable wunderkind
Rabbi Isaac Luria.
Luria and his fellows drew upon
an unbroken mystical tradition
stretching back through the
Renaissance and medieval Italy
to Spain, Provence,
and ultimately Israel,
as far back as the Temple Periods.
The term "kabbalah"
in fact literally means
that which is received.
Luria and his community of fellow
mystics received a tradition
that had been the secretive
study of an exclusive group
of the most sophisticated Jewish
scholars for over 2000 years.
And they revolutionize that
tradition by opening it
up to the greater Jewish community
through this ecstatic prayer
service, enabling the study
of kabbalah to reach
the general community.
The whole Hasidic movement,
beginning in mid-18th
century Ukraine, in fact,
grew from the popularization of
Jewish mysticism that was sparked
by the Luria kabbalah
Shabbat tradition.
As men and women of the dawn of the
21st century, who heard the news
when the Nobel Prize was
awarded for dating the Big Bang,
I think many of us need more
than biblical commandment
or vague spiritual feelings
or even ecstatic joy
in singing beloved
liturgies together
to fully appreciate the grandeur of
the relationship with the divine.
This is true not only
in the Jewish world,
which is what my work deals with,
but for all religions in our time.
It is essential that we understand
our relationship with the divine
through not only the spiritual
but also through the tangible
and physical aspects of our minds.
We live in an age when organized
religion too often seems more
focused on organization than on
spirituality, and is being abandoned
by much of Western society.
A couple of years ago, the Pew
study on religion sounded the alarm
for all American religious
communities, Jewish as well,
that we need to find new ways
of keeping our communities
engaged in our tradition.
Paradoxically though, the need
for moral and spiritual rootedness
in a frightening and
nihilistic world increasingly so,
has never been keener.
To me, an essential question
in religious life is how
to satisfy the hungry and
demanding minds of people planted
in the material world of data and
science and still give them a portal
into the world of the spirit,
of the historical panoply
of religious community on thought,
maintaining the integrity
of the tradition.
For instance, in the Jewish
world, few have to be convinced
of the importance of Friday
night Sabbath dinners.
But in my 30 years of
interviewing hundreds
of young couples toward designing
their Jewish marriage contracts,
I've seen that family Sabbath
and festival dinners are the single
most important, powerful conveyor
of joy in Jewish tradition
from one generation to another.
However, at the same time,
all the numbers are showing
that the family dinner experience
alone doesn't convey the tradition.
That a Jewish feeling alone
doesn't convey the tradition.
That even singing the blessings and
songs doesn't give our children,
even ourselves all too
often, compelling reasons
to bond to our traditions.
In our fast-paced, data-driven
world, in this marketplace of ideas,
we need to have a real-world
reason to drop everything
on Friday afternoon and focus
instead on spiritual matters.
Now we have to find a way of
making it all makes sense,
to show all our generations that
the world, that our daily experience
and the world of our
souls are in fact one.
I think that part of the problem is
that too often organized
religion requires us
to divide our brains in half.
Half, for instance, accepts
the empirical science spun
out of the theory of the Big Bang.
While half of the brain believes
that the world was
created in six days.
And I'd like to share with you
the journey that has helped me
to resolve this dichotomy,
through fusing poetry and metaphor,
paint, parchment, and gold.
Let me tell you how I
embarked upon this trip.
It has led me to places
I never expected to go.
Now, I come from a long line of
Jewish scholars and rabbis descended
from the celebrated 18th-century
Hasidic Master [foreign language].
But in recent generations,
the family consciousness
became more aligned
with more normative rationalist
Jewish rabbinic thought
than with the primarily mystical.
My beloved late first husband
David was a NASA astrophysicist.
And I found his and his
colleagues work entrancing.
His career led me to
become entirely comfortable
in the intellectual world of
modern physics and science,
and more than slightly skeptical
about a more mystical approach
to existence than that native to
mainstream traditional Judaism.
I'm showing you now a
Hubble Space Telescope image
of the extreme deep field of space.
Showing us lights in the universe
arriving now, or better in 2014,
when this image was made.
But emitted as far back
as the early universe.
So take a good look at this photo.
You're going to find
that it's a central image
in the paintings I'm showing you
here and throughout the book.
Deciding to work on the
gorgeous kabbalah Shabbat customs
and liturgy, presented
me though with a problem.
Obviously, I had to confront
Jewish mysticism head on to begin
to make head or tail of it.
Now, mysticism, as I mentioned, had
never been on my intellectual radar.
But at the same time, I knew
it was a serious matter not
to be toyed with carelessly.
In fact, right at the beginning
of my work in the Jewish arts,
I was horrified at
the careless approach
with which I saw kabbalah
misused in the arts community.
And early on, I decided that I would
never touch kabbalah unless I was
prepared to pour myself into it.
When my Song of Songs book came
out in 2005, the renowned scholar
of medieval Jewish mysticism, Arthur
Green, sent me an annoyed email,
criticizing me for working
with midrashic but not
with the cabalistic
allegory on the poetry.
So what else?
Upon deciding to explore
kabbalah Shabbat, I contacted him
to guide my reading, so that
I could begin to orient myself
in the Lurianic mysticism that had
sent forth the Friday night liturgy.
And at the same time, I joined
a little weekly reading group
in Hasidic literature
at my synagogue.
And thunder clap, I discovered
to my complete incredulity
that the questions
and concerns probed
in kabbalah were strikingly
similar to those at the heart
of the scientific world in which
I lived my entire adult life.
Kabbalah seemed to
share the same concerns
as cosmology and particle physics.
Questions concerning the
beginning of the world,
the unity of all matter,
and perpetuating the glorious
order of the world around us.
Now, this was all very perplexing.
I was absolutely certain that my
late husband's, the astrophysicist,
spirit was rolling with laughter
at my colossal misunderstanding.
But soon, I found that a
well-respected astrophysicist,
Howard Smith, who was here at
the Smithsonian for many years
and is now at Harvard, had
explored this very concordance.
And that other biologists
and mathematicians had
been edging toward similar
if not theological ideas
about the unity of all matter.
And at the same time through
my reading on kabbalah,
I also discovered that the sages
who originated key concepts
in Jewish mysticism themselves
understood the mystical realm
of their own experience
through the use of metaphor.
Sort of extreme midrash,
if you will,
for rendering the otherwise
inaccessible reality
of the divine accessible
to human imagination.
And metaphor midrash, for many years
already, these had been as basic
to my work as brushes and paint.
Now, many Jewish thinkers
have written of the unity
of the material and
spiritual worlds.
Rabbi Lord Jonathan Sacks, in his
2011 book, The Great Partnership,
Science, Religion, and the Search
for Meaning, wrote eloquently
of how science and religion
offer not conflicting accounts
of the universe but rather two
complementary points of view.
The first demonstrating
the mechanism
and the second giving
us the meaning.
The 16th and 17th century mystic,
Avraham Azulai, seemed to strain
to describe all the energy
of the universe as the light
of the infinite God head,
which spreads from above,
down to the end of all levels.
And in his lyrical distillation
of Kabbalah, the 13 Petalled Rose,
Adin Steinsaltz tells of how
the soul swings between reaching
for the divine and plunging
into the physical world.
That this oscillation is the
very nature of life itself.
In both the assent to God and the
decent to matter, there is holiness.
Never is any one-way holy
sufficient unto itself.
And it's only when
they exist together
that they constitute a real
passage between heaven and earth.
Yet, how to keep all of this
in mind while actually
living out traditions?
Illuminating Kabbalat
Shabbat would offer a chance
to fuse our traditions and prayer
not only with imagery drawn
from the Kabbalistic sources and my
usual combination of Bible midrash
and archaeology, but also with
science, astrophysics, and biology.
This quickly became my means
of broadening our understanding
of the Sabbath to reflect not only
a spiritual sense of the completion
of the world but also a
view of the tangible unity
of all matter understood
through cosmology and physics.
As I mentioned before, we live in
the millennium, forget millennium,
we live in the decade in which
astrophysicists pinpointed the Big
Bang through the cosmic
microwave background radiation.
We have dated the moment
of "in the beginning."
So here in front of me
lay my next challenge
in creating an interpretation of
Jewish tradition that would engage,
fuse our emotional, spiritual
hearts with our analytic,
space-age, information-age minds.
And many for the science
and a real-world context
for the mysticism.
Off to the races.
So now, put on your virtual
stereo vision glasses
and let's consider how all
this works in just a few
of these painted prayers.
You'll be able see
them all in the book.
For the last minute or
so, you've been looking
at my illuminated paintings of Psalm
96, the second in a series of Psalms
that lie at the heart of the
synagogue kabbalat Shabbat liturgy.
Who of us standing at the seashore
amid the clamor of thundering waves
and rustling palms,
has not been dumbstruck
at the dramatic power
of the created world.
And that I think is exactly what has
caught the psalmist attention here.
And so in these paintings,
the singing of the wind
through the trees, the roaring
of the waves, and energy rushing
through the ever-evolving
heavens, announce the presence
of God in the physical world.
And if you look at these black and
colored bands lining the texts,
these present the spectral
admission lines,
effectively the light signature for
the gases most prevalent in air.
You can begin to see here
how I confuse the physics,
the material world of our daily
experience, with the spiritual.
Now, Psalm 96 is the second in
a series of psalms at the heart
of the Kabbalat Shabbat
synagogue service.
Each of which, to me, leads
us to experience the grandeur
of creation using a
different kind of sense.
My partner in this project, the
scholar of medieval Hebrew poetry,
who translated all the poetry
and wrote the literary analyses,
Raymond Scheindlin, a few years
ago, he stood here to share
with you his new book
on Judah Halevi.
Ray suggests that these psalms must
have seemed a most appropriate way
of stimulating the worshipers
to meditate on the meaning
of the Sabbath as remembrance
of the work of creation.
For them, the Sabbath was more
than a mere act of remembrance.
It was a reenactment
and a prefiguration.
By properly observing the
Sabbath, the worshiper participates
in renewing the original
act of creation,
helping to guarantee the fecundity
of the world for the coming week.
The poem Yedid Nefesh, Souls
Beloved, is a luscious love poem
and song to god by the 16th-century
sought Kabbalist [foreign language],
one of your [foreign
language] companions.
And my illuminations
play on the idea
of the passionate love it expresses
between god and the human soul.
Obzekrid [phonetic] describes god as
the soul's beloved, soul's father,
soul's light, soul's
protector, soul's glory.
Always returning to the intimate
language of romantic love
to express the depth of
human emotion to god.
Whether father, healing
light, or protective king,
god is the intimate
eternal beloved of the soul.
The microcopy that you see, the
lines of tiny writing that you see,
winding through the paintings,
includes the full text
of the biblical Song of Songs.
The love poetry that inspired the
themes of divine and erotic love
and union that pervade
Jewish mysticism.
Other imagery, the intense
love of a father for his baby.
A gazelle, this gazelle nested
securely in the forest floor,
captures other qualities
of the human --
of the warm human love for the
divine that the poet expresses.
And these scenes reflect also the
unity of the whole biological world,
the whole material world.
Our history also unites us.
The columns of palmets [phonetic]
that you see flanking
the text are adapted
from a little ivory furniture
plaque now in the Israel museum
that was found in Samaria, and
which is exactly contemporary
with the building of
Solomon's temple and palace.
In the biblical books
of Kings and Chronicles,
palmets [phonetic] patterns are
described for those great buildings.
And there's perfectly solid art
historical reason to suspect
that this pattern is the
very one that was used
in decorating those great buildings.
And so I use these palmets
[phonetic] often in my work,
to allude to the importance of the
temple as god's dwelling on earth
and the historical unity of Jewish
community across time and geography.
There's much more detailed symbolism
in each of these paintings,
but I'll let you read
about that in the book.
But, again, the infant and the force
imagery remind us of the importance
of living our spiritual
life through the wonders
of the natural world
that we inhabit.
One of the signal ways in which
Jews sanctify the 25 hours
of the Sabbath is with the
Kiddush, the blessing over wine
at the beginning of
the Sabbath meals.
Now, in the Kabbalistic sources,
wine is a symbol of divine wisdom.
And the Sabbath is the time
that wisdom flows most
abundantly into the material realm.
My interpretations of kiddush
present the mystical idea
of the wine's translation of divine
wisdom into the material world
through a mathematical metaphor.
So here at right, the Hebrew
lumination plays with the image
of the wine fountains, with
which many Jews share kiddush
with the family and
friends at our tables.
These cups though aren't arrayed
on the typical tiered trays
but pipe wine from the
uppermost to the lower cups.
And this wine is much more
than fermented grape
juice, even the best.
Instead, this wine overflows
from one level to the next,
following the mystical metaphor that
describes how divine wisdom flows
from the highest, most
hidden aspects of god,
downward until it reaches
the material world,
and finally appears to us as water.
The 10 cups refer, if you haven't
already guessed, to the 10 sefirot,
or emanations, or qualities of god.
And they're presented here in
colors associated with each
of them in the zohar [phonetic].
But what's this pyramid
arrangement all about?
Now, just as the kabbalistic system
ascribes the number 10 cosmic
significance -- for instance, the 10
sefirot -- Pythagorean philosophy,
the beginning of Western
mathematics,
also regard the number 10 as holy.
They describe the tech
tractors [phonetic],
the pyramid symbolizing the unity
of the universe that's formed
by the flow of geometric
form from a single point.
The four levels of these cups
Pythagorean pyramid trace the
development of geometric
form as follows.
At top, the single cup
represents a single point.
At the second level, the two cups
represent the two points necessary
to determine a line.
At the third level, the three
cups are the three points defining
a plane.
And finally, at bottom, the four
cups are the four points necessary
to determine a tetrahedron, the
simplest three-dimensional form.
The microcopy surrounding both
these pages is the passage
from Proverbs 8, in which
wisdom, personified as a woman,
rejoices in being the
almighty's first companion
from before creation.
And how she takes pleasure, not only
in being god's closest companion,
but also a playmate of
humankind, bridging the divide
between heaven and earth.
Since time is short,
I'll leave you to find
out about the English
painting in the book.
This is all about Luria's
ideas about the sweetness
of the sheena's presence on earth.
I love the kabbalistic notion
of how we draw divine wisdom
into the world on the Sabbath.
As we saw, blessing wine is an
important means of doing this,
but we begin the process by lighting
Sabbath candles a few minutes
before sunset.
My own private prayer, after
blessing the candles, in fact,
asks for wisdom for guiding my
family and to imbue my work.
In these paintings of candle
lighting, I fuse the light
of the candles with the
lights of material creation.
There's so much going on here.
Medieval poetry and [foreign
language] historical women's
meditations, my mother's and
grandmother's candlesticks,
and all that's explained
in the book.
But right now, let me just
focus on the sources of light.
First though, a few words about
the origin and mystical role
of Sabbath candle lighting.
The ritual began in the
period of the Mishnah,
that is in the first couple of
centuries of the Common Era,
during the period of the first
codification of Jewish law.
And it was begun simply
to light the Sabbath table
so that family could relax
and enjoy their festive meal
and Sabbath rest together
at leisure.
Mystical sources though
suggests that the light
from the Sabbath candles adds
to the [foreign language],
the additional soul that
flowers within the soul
of every Jew during the Sabbath.
Now, this [foreign
language], additional soul,
descends from the feminine emanation
of god, the [foreign language],
the divine emanation
closest in material world.
It's the woman of the house
who enjoys the privilege
of lighting the candles, reenacting
the unification of the human
and divine spheres, of the sphere
of the emanations themselves.
So let's focus for a moment on
the Hebrew illumination at right.
Let's start with the
candle flames at the center.
Their blue and gold motif
represents the [foreign language],
the divine energy flowing
throughout the universe.
We view the candles against the
dusk sky lit by the setting sun,
while the ever-evolving
deep sky wheels far
above our heads and homes.
Now, this image is taken from that
same Hubble photograph I showed you
earlier, showing lights of
origin so distant that it comes
from the earliest periods
after the Big Bang.
The geometric painting
surrounding the words
of the blessing is a
classical Moorish pattern,
that was part of the visual
surroundings of the Sephardic world,
the world of the Spanish Jews.
This pattern expresses the
flow of all geometric form
from a single point, symbolizing
the origin of all the universe
and the creator whose work
we celebrate on the Sabbath.
There's so much to share here
about the beauty of the Sabbath
and the fusion of the
spiritual with the scientific,
and there are many
themes in this book
that I haven't even
begun to deal with today.
But let me show you just two more
pairs of paintings that relate
to one of the most popular ways
that we experience the material
world as the Sabbath arrives.
Food. Challah, the special
braided egg bread that we eat
on the Sabbath, is not
only the first thing eaten
at the Sabbath dinner, but the
bread symbolizes all the bounty
of the feast.
And the act of baking
it most weeks is part
of my own spiritual
preparation for the Sabbath.
At right, I'm showing you
a meditation and painting
about the act of kneading
the challah dough.
And you can see in the bottom
left corner, right here,
a little blob of dividing
yeast cells,
that bit of microbiology
that defines bread.
Above and below the painting,
you'll see a little meditation
about the spiritual significance
of kneading the dough.
This was a remarkable find for
me since these are the words
of my ancestress pearl, the wife
of Rabbi [foreign language].
At left, the blessing itself
surrounds an image expressing the
mystical significance of the
act of breaking the bread.
The shadowy winged figures represent
the seraphim, who, as you'll read
in the book, mystic
suggested to him the feast.
The two loaves are set within a
view of the deep cosmos, again,
that Hubble photograph, suggesting
the all suffusing divine,
and the hills of Judah
burgeoning with the wheat harvest.
And after the meal,
after singing some songs,
all of which are also
here, we thank the almighty
for the bounty of creation.
Jewish tradition precedes the
grace after meals with Psalm 126,
that we describe as Shir Ha'maalot.
And these paintings tie
the miracle of the rebirth
of the Jewish homeland, about
which the psalm remembers dreaming,
to the biological and
agricultural wonder of bringing food
from our sacred soil once again.
There's some wonderful
archaeology here.
Imagery from Orr [phonetic],
Abraham's home,
from the first Temple Period and
from the early Byzantine Period.
But I want to draw your attention
to the two agricultural paintings.
At right, the semicircular
painting shows a woman,
the mourning woman Jerusalem
of Jeremiah, traipsing away
from her destroyed home,
dragging a bag of seed.
What she can't see happening
behind her is that water,
a symbol of wisdom and torah
throughout our sources,
is starting to flow again, and
those seeds falling from her bag,
they're actually beginning
to germinate.
Above her, the deep sky reminds
us of the all suffusing presence
of the divine, of the unity
of the entire physical world.
At left, we flash forward to the
miracle of the modern rebirth
of the land and the
advent of modern Israel.
The locale incidentally in both
of these paintings is a
spot on [foreign language].
Now, the dream of the
resettlement of Israel is reality.
And again we draw sustenance
from the land.
The fields and hills sprout with
date palms, crops, and vines.
And farm workers use
tractors to harvest the bounty
for which we give thanks
as we end the evening.
I hope that these paintings
at your table will spur discussion
among both adults and children
about what it means to
celebrate the Sabbath.
I've developed a small paperback
bench or table side condition
of the home and table
materials, so that all can share
and discuss the text, the paintings,
and the vibrant ideas
within them all.
So we see that there
really isn't any division.
Instead, we have a unification
of the scientific world
of our daily experience
and the mystical world
revealed to us on the Sabbath.
We just need to put on
our stereo vision glasses.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library Of Congress.
Visit us@LOC.gov.